ISSUE.
>> LET ME ASK YOU, JUST GETTING
TO HIS QUESTION, WE'VE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT SENATOR MANCHIN AND
SENATOR SINEMA.
YOU SEEM RELATIVELY CONFIDENT
YOU CAN KIND OF GET SENATOR
MANCHIN ON BOARD.
THERE'S A LOT OF DEMOCRATS IN
THE HOUSE AND SENATE WHO ARE
CONFUSED ABOUT WHERE SENATOR
SINEMA ACTUALLY STANDS ON
THINGS.
AND I KNOW SHE'S BEEN
NEGOTIATING DIRECTLY WITH YOU
AND THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT IS YOUR READ ON HER?
AND OBVIOUSLY, YOU NEED HER TO
REMAIN POSITIVE IN YOUR
DIRECTION.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY.
BUT WHAT IS YOUR READ ON HER?
DO YOU KNOW WHERE SHE STANDS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, SHE'S SMART AS
THE DEVIL, NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, SHE'S VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
AGENDA IN MY LEGISLATION.
VERY SUPPORTIVE.
SHE'S SUPPORTIVE OF ALMOST ALL
OF THE THINGS I MENTIONED
RELATING TO EVERYTHING FROM
FAMILY CARE TO ALL THOSE ISSUES.
WHERE SHE'S NOT SUPPORTIVE IS
SHE SAYS SHE WILL NOT RAISE A
SINGLE PENNY IN TAXES ON THE
CORPORATE SIDE AND ON WEALTHY
PEOPLE, PERIOD.
SO THAT'S WHERE IT SORT OF
BREAKS DOWN.
THERE'S A FEW OTHER ISSUES IT
BREAKS DOWN ON.
BUT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
REACH A POINT HERE WHERE I'M
ABLE TO PRESENT TO THE SENATE,
ABLE TO VOTE ON, AND THE HOUSE A
SERIOUS, SERIOUS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT CHANGES THE
DYNAMIC FOR WORKING-CLASS FOLKS
IN AMERICA AND MIDDLE-CLASS
FOLKS AND BEGINS TO HAVE THE
VERY WEALTHY AND CORPORATIONS
JUST BEGIN TO PAY THEIR FAIR
SHARE.
NOT A LOT.
HOW WE GET THERE, WE'RE DOWN TO
FOUR OR FIVE ISSUES WHERE I'M
NOT GOING TO NEGOTIATE ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION, AS YOU
MIGHT GUESS.
>> WE'D BE INTERESTED IN HEARING
THEM IF YOU WANT.
>> I KNOW.
BUT ALL KIDDING ASIDE, I THINK
WE CAN GET THERE.
>> YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PIECE.
YOU SAID SENATOR SINEMA IS ON
BOARD WITH THAT.
CERTAINLY SENATOR MANCHIN IS
NOT.
IT GETS TO OUR NEXT QUESTION.
THIS IS FROM KOBE KONG.
HE'S ORIGINALLY FROM ANAHEIM,
CALIFORNIA.
HE'S SOPHOMORE CLASS PRESIDENT
AT JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY.
A DEMOCRAT.
KOBE, WHAT'S YOUR QUESTION?
>> MR. PRESIDENT.
>> ONE OF THE LARGEST ISSUES
THAT PEOPLE HAVE TROUBLE
COMPREHENDING THE SEVERITY OF IS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
MANY LEGISLATORS AND POLITICIANS
TODAY ARE LENIENT AS THEY WON'T
HAVE TO LIVE WITH THE FUTURE
EFFECTS.
WITHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT
FOR THE CLIMATE ASPECTS OF YOUR
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND THE EARTH
RAPIDLY APPROACHING THE PARIS
AGREEMENT'S 1.5 DEGREES LIMIT,
WHAT OTHER BACKUP PLANS DO YOU
HAVE TO ENSURE A FUTURE FOR THE
NEXT GENERATIONS?
>> MR. PRESIDENT, YOU GOT IT
RIGHT.
THE EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO
HUMANITY IS CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP PULLED
OUT OF THE PARIS ACCORD, WHICH
WHEN I WAS WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WE HELPED
NEGOTIATE, THE AGREEMENT WAS
THAT WE COULD NOT -- IF WE
REACHED BEYOND 1.5 DEGREES
CELSIUS INCREASE IN TEMPERATURE
WE'RE GONE.
NOT A JOKE.
AND SO WE DECIDED THAT -- HE
PULLED OUT.
FIRST THING I COMMITTED TO DO IS
REJOIN THAT ACCORD.
NUMBER ONE.
BUT NUMBER TWO.
NUMBER TWO, WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO
IS LOOK AT MULTIPLE WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN DEAL WITH CLIMATE.
I'M GOING OFF TO COP 26 IN
SCOTLAND IN I GUESS IT'S TWO
WEEKS OR A WEEK.
I'M LOSING TRACK OF TIME.
AND I'M PRESENTING A COMMITMENT
TO THE WORLD THAT WE WILL IN
FACT GET TO NET ZERO EMISSIONS
ON ELECTRIC POWER BY 2035 AND
NET ZERO EMISSIONS ACROSS THE
BOARD BY 2050 OR BEFORE.
BUT WE HAVE TO DO SO MUCH
BETWEEN NOW AND 2030 TO
DEMONSTRATE WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO.
LET ME GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES.
>> LET ME JUST FOLLOW UP VERY
QUICKLY ON THAT.
THE KEY CLIMATE PROVISION THAT
WAS IN THE BUILD BACK BETTER
PLAN AS YOU CALL IT, THE CLEAN
ELECTRICITY PERFORMANCE PROGRAM,
THAT'S BEEN DROPPED NOW FROM THE
SPENDING BILL --
>> NO, IT HASN'T.
>> IT HAS NOT.
BUT SENATOR MANCHIN IS OPPOSED
TO THAT.
>> HE'S OPPOSED TO IT.
BUT HERE'S THE DEAL.
THAT IS ONLY ONE OF WELL OVER,
WELL OVER A TRILLION DOLLARS'
WORTH OF EXPENDITURES FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT'S $150 BILLION.
IT'S IMPORTANT.
AND WHAT IT SAYS IS THAT IF IN
FACT A UTILITY DOESN'T PULL BACK
AND CONTINUE TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF CARBON THAT THEY EMIT
THAT WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS THEY
WILL END UP PAYING A PENALTY.
AND SO THERE'S A PENALTY
INCURRED.
JOE MANCHIN'S ARGUMENT IS LOOK,
WE STILL HAVE COAL IN MY STATE,
YOU'RE GOING TO ELIMINATE IT
EVENTUALLY, WE KNOW IT'S GOING
AWAY, WE KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE
GONE, BUT DON'T RUSH IT SO FAST
THAT MY PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO.
I THINK THAT'S NOT WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS WE
CAN TAKE THAT 150 BILLION, ADD
IT TO THE 320 BILLION THAT'S IN
THE LAW NOW THAT HE'S PREPARED
TO SUPPORT FOR TAX INCENTIVES.
TAX INCENTIVES TO HAVE PEOPLE
ACT IN A WAY THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO DO THE THINGS THAT
THEY NEED TO DO.
FOR EXAMPLE, IF YOU'VE GOT
WINDOWS THAT ARE -- THE WIND'S
BLOWING THROUGH YOU GET AN
INCENTIVE TO PUT NEW WINDOWS IN
YOUR HOME.
HELP GET IT PAID.
WE'RE GOING TO SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE THE AMOUNT, THE COST OF
SOLAR PANELS ON YOUR ROOF.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUALLY --
FOR EXAMPLE, THERE'S A NEW
BATTERY TECHNOLOGY BEING -- I
WENT OUT IN SILICON VALLEY,
THERE'S A BATTERY THAT'S ABOUT
THAT WIDE AND ABOUT THAT THICK.
IF YOU HAVE SOLAR POWER, YOU PUT
THAT IN YOUR BASEMENT AND THE
SUN DOESN'T SHINE FOR SEVEN DAYS
YOU STILL HAVE ALL THE POWER YOU
NEED.
>> BUT THE CONCESSION HAS BEEN
AGREED TO FOR SENATOR MANCHIN
FOR COAL IN HIS STATE.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> NOTHING HAS BEEN FORMALLY
AGREED TO.
THE NEGOTIATION IS I'VE BEEN
SAYING TO JOE, LOOK, I'LL
TAKE -- IF WE DON'T DO IT IN
TERMS OF THE ELECTRIC GRID PIECE
WHAT WE'LL DO IS GIVE ME THAT
$150 BILLION.
I'M GOING TO ADD IT TO BE ABLE
TO DO OTHER THINGS THAT ALLOW ME
TO DO OTHER THINGS THAT DON'T
DIRECTLY AFFECT THE ELECTRIC
GRID IN THE WAY THAT THERE'S A
PENALTY BUT ALLOW ME TO SPEND
THE WAY TO SET NEW TECHNOLOGIES
IN PLACE.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE CAN SAVE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF MONEY AND
AS A CONSEQUENCE OF THAT
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF ENERGY IF
IN FACT WE ARE ABLE TO PUT THE
HIGH TENSION WIRES UNDERGROUND.
IT COSTS A HELL OF A LOT MORE TO
DO IT.
IT CREATES REAL GOOD JOBS.
IT CREATES A HELL OF A LOT MORE
TO DO IT.
BUT IN FACT, IT WOULD DO A LOT
TO KEEP THINGS FROM HAPPENING
THAT ARE DANGEROUS.
HALF THE FOREST FIRES OUT WEST
ARE THOSE TOWERS COMING DOWN,
SETTING FIRES, ET CETERA.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS JOE
IS OPEN TO MY CONVINCING HIM
THAT I CAN USE IT TO INCREASE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRESS WITHOUT